I'm an optimist despite many reasons for
being concerned it's easy to get
depressed looking at what's happening
Japan coming in and and really
interfering with a process that might
have given hope for bluefin tuna at the
site ease conference that that would
have inhibited trade international trade
for these greatly endangered magnificent
creatures that's cause for despair but
it also ignites a kind of increased
desire to go out and do something that
will change things to turn it around so
you pull out of the jaws of defeat
something that looks like greater
reasons for hope one reason that I have
for being an optimist is that we have
means of communication now that didn't
exist even ten years ago I look at the
phenomenon called Google Earth and how
the Googlers have stepped up and not
only used this wonderful form at Google
Earth to inform people about what's
happening on the land but now to fill
out the ocean there's now an ocean in
Google Earth with hope spots embedded in
it so anyone any little kid any grown-up
any CEO any teacher any fisherman
anybody can hold the world in their
hands and see what's happening with the
information that is embedded within
Google Earth within google ocean you can
go trek mission blue you can engage with
a scientist you can send messages to
others around the other side of the
planet and instantly they'll find
answers or they'll get and it right
answer you this to me is the greatest
reason for hope that we're developing
this fabric of knowledge with people who
once they know may be inspired to care
it's the only thing that will cause
people to kr knowing and with knowing
the caring that comes there is
cause for hope it will find an enduring
place for ourselves within the natural
world the natural systems mostly blue
they keep us alive
you